There was a homeschooling mum.
I'm always trying to find some cool,
fun ways to get the lesson across to my kids.
Me and my older son Bowie
are starting a geology unit study and he's super excited.
He loves rugs. What boy doesn't?
Now, I truly believe when you have something physically in front of you,
it's a lot easier to retain the information.
So to make this unit study even more fun,
we have the rocks, we have the sand,
and it's gonna be such an amazing lesson.
These are available on TikTok Shop.
They come in a multiple different sizes,
even have specialist ones
that have certain types of crystals and rocks in them.
I'm gonna put this in the link
so you can hit this on the video and grab yours.
Now, if you're a homeschooling mom
or you just starting out Christmas presents early,
check out this super fun store
and all the cool tubs and rocks they have.